the ipad pro is finally starting to gain
traction
as an actual laptop replacement and we
know this because the last version of
this video
has gained 618 000 views in nine months
so there are a lot of people wondering
if they can just buy an ipad
pro instead of a macbook so in this
video
we're actually going to compare the 2020
macbook air
that's priced at a thousand dollars the
2020 base 13 inch macbook pro
for hundred dollars and the twenty
twenty ipad pro
for eight hundred dollars but this year
there's a very important change
to this comparison we now have the magic
keyboard case
for the ipad pro and this thing is no
regular keyboard
case it adds an incredibly great
trackpad
an excellent keyboard and other features
as well
just take a look at this x-ray image
taken by ifixit
and you'll understand how complex this
accessory really is now while i can't
agree that 300
for it is expensive i still fully
believe that it's worth it
because it actually becomes a true
laptop replacement
for the first time ever so with the
magic keyboard case
this ipad pro setup becomes eleven
hundred dollars
priced right around in the middle of
these two macbooks
now the question is which one do you
choose in 2020
i'll answer that in just a minute but
first let's compare
everything we can between these apple
laptops
in terms of weight the 11 inch ipad pro
with a magic keyboard case
weighs 2.36 pounds quite a bit less than
the macbook air
and the macbook pro the ipad pro setup
is thinner than the macbook air at its
thickest point
but much thicker than the front end of
the air
but compared to the macbook pro there's
not that much of a difference
as far as portability the ipad pro is
definitely the best choice for carrying
around
because of its small size however one of
the downsides is that it's harder to
open the display
compared to the macbooks but i found a
pretty decent solution
put it down on the hinge first and it
becomes easier to pull the keyboard
section down
but either way the macbooks are still
better in this area
now as far as the hinge it's easier to
adjust on the macbooks and you get a
wider range of adjustability
than on the ipad pro's magic keyboard
case but the ipad does have a really
unique floating design
which places the display closer to you
this makes it much easier to use touch
input since it is a touch screen device
unlike the macbooks
which don't have that added
functionality the major benefit for the
ipad pro is that you can easily lift it
off the magic keyboard case
and use it as a tablet which you can't
do at all
on the macbooks and of course there's
the apple pencil support which works
great on the ipad pro
which obviously does not work at all on
either of these macbooks
now getting into the keyboards the new
scissor switch keys on the macbooks are
much better than the previous butterfly
keys
giving you a lot more key travel than
before the ipad pro has the same
key switches and key travel but they
feel more clicky
compared to the ones on the macbooks
which can feel a little bit soft when
you press them down all the way
so some people might actually prefer the
ones on the ipad pro better the best
part is that the ipad pro supports all
of the same keyboard shortcuts that you
get on the macbooks
so there isn't any downside there
however the macbooks feature an escape
key
with function keys or a touch bar at the
top which can be used to conveniently
adjust the brightness volume and other
features like keyboard backlighting
the magic keyboard unfortunately doesn't
get this so it definitely loses in this
area but there are some decent
alternatives like rerouting the escape
key to a different key
using the control center and the
trackpad to adjust brightness and volume
and as for the backlighting it's
actually fully automated
by using the ambient light sensor built
into the ipad pro
so those extra keys aren't a deal
breaker the main downside is that the
keyboard on the 11 inch ipad pro's case
is not a full sized keyboard but
thankfully
it doesn't take that long to get used to
the smaller size the macbooks also use
the touch id sensor for authentication
but i much prefer face id on the ipad
pro since it works instantly and
automatically
as for the track pads the ones on the
macbooks are solid state track pads made
of glass
which means that they don't actually
move or physically click
they simply sense the pressure of your
finger and then trigger the haptic motor
simulating a click but on the magic
keyboard case
it actually does physically click with a
really nice lever based design
that gives you an even clicking feel
anywhere on the track pad
compared to the traditional diving board
track pads which are hard to click at
the top
and since it also uses a glass panel it
feels just as smooth as on the macbooks
and the best part is that it supports
the same features like tap to click
two finger tap to right click and all
the same two finger
and three finger gestures and to my
surprise
these gestures work incredibly well with
no lag at all
because of the physical smart connector
used to connect the keyboard case
to the ipad pro but as for which track
pads work better
i definitely have to say that the
macbook trackpads are the best
especially since they're much larger
than the one on the magic keyboard case
as for the displays the one on the ipad
pro
is better than on the macbooks because
it's brighter than the other two
while getting the same great p3 color
accuracy as the macbook pro
and it also features pro motion 120
hertz display technology
which gives you a much smoother
experience for swiping through apps or
playing games at 120 fps
while also giving you better battery
life when you're watching something like
a 24 fps video
so the display on the ipad pro is
definitely the clear winner
and for those who like larger displays
there's the 12.9 inch ipad pro
but that'll bring the price up to 1350
with the magic keyboard case
more than the base models of these
macbooks as for speaker quality
the macbook's definitely beat out the
ipad pro in this scenario
just listen for
[Music]
world yourself silver
[Music]
now on the flip side the facetime camera
on the ipad pro is much better than on
the macbooks
but the downside is that the camera is
on the side when you're using it with a
magic keyboard case
this is an audio and video quality test
on the 2020 macbook air
this is an audio in video quality tests
on the 2020 macbook pro
this is an audio and video quality test
on the 2020 ipad pro
and another plus for the ipad pro is
that it has rear cameras
including a wide lens an ultra wide lens
and a lidar scanner
for augmented reality apps so that's
something you can't get on a macbook
now both of these macbooks get headphone
jacks which is missing on the ipad pro
so you'll have to use an adapter the
macbooks also get
two high-speed thunderbolt 3 ports for
connecting demanding devices
like external graphics cards and high
resolution displays
the ipad pro on the other hand has a
single usbc
port but the great thing about the magic
keyboard case is that it adds an
extra port on the hinge which can be
used solely for charging the ipad
pro freeing up the main port for
connecting things like external storage
and other devices and while it's nowhere
near as good for file management as the
macbooks are
the new ipad os features can get the job
done if you need to store or transfer
files now finally getting into
performance using geekbench 5 cpu test
the ipad pro surprisingly beats out both
of these macbooks
and that's because it uses a custom
apple arm chip
and in recent years the performance of
these chips
has been growing much faster than the
performance of the traditional intel
chips
as for graphics performance using the
metal test the ipad pro
once again beats the other two macbooks
out by a pretty significant amount
now the macbook air does have the option
to upgrade to the i5
quad-core cpu which has much better
graphics for a hundred dollars
but the issue with that model is that it
heats up to 100 degrees celsius
very quickly even for common tasks but
for performance tasks
the macbook pro is much faster and one
more thing
the macbooks both have 256 gigs of base
ssd storage
compared to 128 on the ipad pro so
that's a pretty big advantage there now
with all of those things compared
let's get into which apple device you
should buy as a laptop in 2020.
now i believe that each of these laptops
has at least two different markets
where it makes sense to buy them
starting with the macbook air
you have the people who want the
cheapest possible new apple laptop
and you also have the market who want a
basic but traditional laptop
and for those people the macbook air
makes sense
because it's only 950 on amazon right
now
now for the macbook pro you have the
people who want a traditional laptop
but also care about performance let me
repeat that
if you care about performance whatsoever
do not buy the macbook air not even the
quad core model
the base macbook pro will destroy it
because it doesn't quickly overheat
like the air does now the second market
for the macbook pro
is for the people who want to invest a
bit more money to get luxury
improvements that you don't get on the
air
like the better display the better
speakers the touch bar
and less fan noise while doing common
tasks
now for the ipad pro there are actually
three
main markets that apply if you want a
laptop for basic computing needs
like web browsing watching videos
transferring files
and typing documents and you're not
afraid to spend
eleven hundred dollars then the ipad pro
with the magic keyboard case
is an excellent choice since it's more
portable
the second market is for anybody who
cares at all about gaming
there are so many more games on the ios
app store and since ios is so
incredibly well optimized the ipad pro
will do the best job for gaming the
third market is for people who want
great performance for doing professional
tasks
like photo editing and video editing
while on the go
while also having a nice tablet for
tablet things
this ipad pro will be great for those
kinds of people that don't require
apps like final cut pro xcode
and logic pro 10 that you can only get
on mac os
so to try to sum up this entire video
it's really great that with the new
magic keyboard case for the ipad pro
we now finally have a third laptop
option from apple
and no longer have to choose solely
between the macbooks for buyers who want
to spend around a thousand to thirteen
hundred dollars
so hopefully this video helped you guys
decide which one of these three laptops
you should buy
and if it did go ahead and use the links
down below for the best deals on these
laptops but if you're still unsure about
which one to buy
comment your specific situation and use
case down below
and we'll be glad to help you out if you
enjoyed this video go ahead and tap the
like button
and click the circle about to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video